assassinat dimanche dernier à mougins
dans les alpes maritimes de ghislaine
marchal 65 ans qui a été trouvée frappé
deux coups de couteau dans la villa
qu'elle peut être se faire construire il
semble qu'elle ait eu le temps d'écrire
avec son sang sur les murs
le nom de son agresseur pas banal
philippe tallois c'est en lettres de
sang qu'un prénom omar est apparu aux
gendarmes de mougins appelé chez madame
marchal par des voisins inquiets de ne
pas l'avoir trouvée chez elle dimanche
après midi dans une maison restée
ouverte
le crime a dû avoir lieu passé midi car
madame marchal a répondu au téléphone
jusqu'à cette heure là cette belle femme
énergique de 65 ans dont le corps
partiellement dévêtue été retrouvé lundi
dans la chaufferie fermée à clé or à
employer ses dernières forces à dénoncer
l'auteur des multiples coups de couteau
qui l'ont tué omar et le prénom du
jardinier retrouvé dans sa famille à
toulon et transféré à la gendarmerie de
mougins où il est en garde à vue mais il
nie le jour du crime il travaillait à
300 mètres de là précisément chez la
voisine amie qui inquiète s'est déplacé
jusqu'à la maison de madame marchal ne
va pas venir le lundi et alors il m'a
dit je viendrai dimanche
je n'ai pas été derrière lui tout le
temps il fait le jardin mais justement
nous étions trois à la maison
aujourd'hui moi il n'y avait pas
d'invité vend donc
on l'a vu travailler mais ce qui
l'aurait puis s'absenter une demi-heure
mettant sens ça vraiment c'est difficile
à dire mais je dois vraiment ma fille
m'a dit c'est impossible
on a déjeuné dehors il a repris son
travail de l'entente du la baisse à 1h15
et puis alors il est rentré pareil qui
n'était parti le crime a pu être signés
du nom d'un autre part le meurtrier
lequel en tout état de cause ne peut
être qu un familier on attendait
beaucoup des empreintes et divers
indices relevés sur place
omar sera conduit demain matin devant un
juge d'instruction de grasse fait divers
à mougins près de nice le meurtre de
ghislaine marchal la veuve de l'un des
frères marshall connu comme
accessoiriste dans le monde de
l'automobile vous savez les bougies ciel
et farah tête de chat le principal
suspect de ce meurtre est le jardinier
mais les voisins me fournisse un alibi
sur place pour antenne de chantal fanny
c'est ici dans l'atmosphère qu'elle
ferait de cette luxueuse villa à mougins
que le crime a eu lieu
lardée de coups de couteau le corps à
moitié dévêtue dilenn marshall a été
retrouvée morte dans les sous sols de sa
buanderie sur la porte
inscrite en lettres de sang cette petite
phrase omar m'a tuer rapidement
identifié omar un jardinier marocain de
28 ans employé occasionnel de la victime
était alors désigné comme le suspect
numéro un
déféré aujourd'hui devant le parquet de
grasse omar continue pourtant de nier en
bloc les accusations portées contre lui
dimanche le jour du crime il travaillait
chez une voisine à peu près sûr que
c'est pas possible ça soit nuit étant
donné qu'ils travaillaient toute la
journée chez moi ce jour là et que je
n'ai pas vu partir en serre l'instant je
n'ai pas derrière lui tout le temps mais
et que c'était un grand travailleur et
un garçon honnête gentil doux et surtout
travailleurs qui avaient fait pour sa
petite famille
voilà ce jour-là il est arrivé à quelle
heure j'ai vu arriver à 8 à 8 heures du
matin il est parti à 5 heures de l'après
midi on chez moi n'aurait pas pu
s'absenter on pense pas reste une
inconnue
ghislaine marchal est elle vraiment
l'auteur des inscriptions trouvé par les
enquêteurs at elle eu la force de le
faire ou bien s'agit-il d'une mise en
scène montée de toutes pièces par le
vrai meurtrier cette fois est destiné à
accabler omar il faudra
vraisemblablement attendre les résultats
de l'autopsié
elle sera pratiquée demain pour
l'affirmer avec certitude
l'affairé omar qui rebondit au mars et
ce jardinier qui était en prison parce
qu'on l'accuse d'avoir tué ghislaine
marshall une richissime veuve assassiné
cet été sur la côte d'azur
elle avait inscrit avec son sang
souvenez vous avant de mourir le nom
d'omar sur le mur du garage
omar a toujours clamé son innocence et
d'ailleurs il est en grève de la faim
depuis trois semaines à fresnes
mais le juge refuse de le remettre en
liberté pourtant les charges qui pèsent
contre lui ne sont pas bien lourde et
surtout un rapport d'autopsié récent
indiquerait que madame marchal serait
morte le lendemain de ce qu'on avait cru
d'abord cela aussi innocenteraient omar
valérie ermite le point tout de suite
sur cette affaire qui est un véritable
roman policier le 24 juin 91
le corps de la veuve marshall est
découvert par les gendarmes dans la
chaufferie de sa propriété de moujan
personne ne lui connaissait d'ennemis
apparent mais les murs vous parlez en
lettres de sang
les gendarmes découvriront ces mots omar
m'a tuer
omar omar est bien connu dans le
quartier il est le jardinier de madame
marchal et d'une de ses voisines
arrêté il lira tout en bloc mais son
alibi n'est pas vérifiable à 100% les
gendarmes s'en remettront alors à la
science
les laboratoires diront que la phrase
sur le mur a bien été écrite par madame
marchal mais des analyses génétiques
plus fine vont jeter un trouble sur la
culpabilité d'omar
les analyses ont révélé qu'il n'y avait
aucune trace d'omar raddad sur madame
marchal août
la chaufferie ni aucune trace de la
chaufferie ou de madame marchal sur omar
haddad l'énigme est totale d'autant plus
qu'un nouvel élément vient encore
troublé l'enquète madame marchal n'était
plus apparu depuis le 23 juin vers 11h45
c'est cette date ont toujours retenus
les enquêteurs pour situer la mort de
ghislaine marchal
mais un nouveau rapport d'expertisé pas
encore versé au dossier situerait sa
mort et 24 juin et non aux 23 désormais
un élément figure dans le dossier
permettant de penser que le décès
remonterait au 24 juin 1991 entre 12h et
14h or le 24 juin 1991
omar raddad était à toulon et ne peut
donc être le meurtrier de mme marchal
erreur d'écriture ou véritable
disculpation d'omar raddad le mystère
marshall cp site un peu plus de jour en
jour
voilà huit mois que le corps sans vie de
madame marchal a été découvert dans la
chaufferie de sa ville à la chamade sur
les hauteurs de mougins et l'énigme
reste entière
ce n'est pas ce matin le transport de
justice destinée à vérifier certains
indices à la demande des défenseurs
d'omar raddad qui apportera la lumière
l'inculpé était bien là amaigri après
une longue grève de la faim mais surtout
très là selon les termes de cet avocat
par cet acte d'instruction la défense
entendait procéder à certaines
vérifications techniques notamment
relevé de traces de sang qui ont compéti
vos coups de couteau mortels portés au
foie et fermeture de la porte de la
chaufferie par un petit lit en fer et
une barre
la défense estime avoir marqué des
points
[Musique]
la démonstration consistait à prouver
que l'on peut parfaitement abc le leak
qui se trouvait derrière la porte
d'accès à la cades en quittant la cave
cette démonstration nous l'avons fait
que maintenant des points de détail soit
évoquée par les uns ou par les autres
ça suscite peut être de notre part la
réflexion suivante il n'est de pire
sourd que celui qui ne veut entendre
mais en ce qui nous concerne des tout à
l'heure nous déposerons une nouvelle
demande de mise en liberté aux intérêts
de ma raddad
du côté de la partie civile
ce transport sur les lieux n'a apporté
aucun élément nouveau n'a été tué dans
des conditions horribles le 23 juin elle
a écrit une première fois à genoux omar
m'a tuer est une deuxième fois couchée
sur le côté avant de mourir
omar m'a tuer et avant cela elle a
poussé contre la porte un lit une barre
de fer pour empêcher celui qui était
sortie qui avait fermé la porte à clef
de rentrée voilà quelle est ma position
le mystère de la ville à la chamade
demeure entier omar haddad at il tué
madame marchal pour lui dérober de
l'argent ou est-il victime d'un complot
ourdi par un assassin désireux de
détourner les soupçons certitude la
chauffe il ce matin n'a délivré aucun
secret
chapitre de la justice encore avec le
feuilleton homard avec de nouveaux
éléments il s'agit au mars et ce
jardinier qui est en prison parce qu'il
est soupçonné d'avoir tué ghislaine
marchal l'été dernier cette femme qui
avait écrit avec son sang omar m'a tuer
sur les murs de son garage
bref c'est en fait la seule véritable
accusations contre marc mais cet homme
reste en prison et pourtant je vous le
disais il y à de nouveaux éléments à son
dossier est dans les deux sens valérie
ermite un crime et le nom du coupable
écrit en lettres de sang sur les murs
l'histoire de la veuve marshall et de
son assassin présumé omar haddad aurait
pu être simple pourtant après sept mois
d'enquêté les avocats du jardinier
marocain multiplient leurs contre
attaques
pour eux pas question d'accepter comme
une évidence
la date retenue pour la mort de
ghislaine marchal à savoir le 23 juin
dans une démonstration presque médico
légal ils viennent de reposer au juge
des questions très précises sur les
circonstances et la datation de la mort
la manoeuvre est simple si madame
marchal mais pas morte le 23 juin
mais le 24 omar est innocent ce jour là
il est à toulon pas voir enfin des
réponses
et puis enfin des certitudes sur les
circonstances dates et circonstances du
décès de madame marchal le rôle de la
justice n'est pas de trouver un coupable
mais de trouver à un crime
le coupable une défense virulente qui
n'ébranle pas vraiment les convictions
des enquêteurs pour eux omar n'est pas
un coupable mais le coupable
le mobile c'est l'argent plus de 2000
francs ont été dérobés dans le sac à
main de la victime omar raddad est un
joueur il aurait été à court d'argent
enfin une nouvelle expertise vient de
les conforter
des traces de poussière et de laine de
verre ont été retrouvés sur le pantalon
d'omar elle pourrait provenir de la
chaufferie la défense riposte
omar n'a jamais nié y être allé étrange
affaire où après sept mois d'enquêté
pousser et de multiples expertises omar
haddad
n'est toujours ni vraiment coupable ni
vraiment innocent un non lieu ou la cour
d'assises pour omar raddad on sera fixée
prochainement au marais ce jardinier de
mougins qui est accusé du meurtre de
ghislaine marchal
la veuve de l'empereur des accessoires
automobiles l'instruction est terminée
le dossier sera examiné cet après midi
par la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel d'aix-en-provence
mais ce n'est que dans deux semaines au
mieux qu'on connaîtra la décision de la
justice dominique verdeilhan daniel
lefebvre de dos entouré de trois
gendarmes
omar raddad c'était en février 92 huit
mois après les faits lors d'une
reconstitution dans le pavillon de
ghislaine marshall une riche héritière
retrouvée morte barricadés dans la
chaufferie de sa ville à la chamade
elle a succombé à une longue agonie
après avoir été blessés de neuf coups de
poignard seul indice un témoignage
posthume de la victime écrit avec son
propre sang omar m'a tuer tuer er drôle
de fautes pour une adepte des mots
croisés et c'est ici après deux ans
d'enquêté le seul élément à charge
contre le jardinier car l'examen de son
emploi du temps le jour du meurtre
n'apporte aucune certitude au mardi
avoir quitté son travail chez madame
pascale à 12h puis s'être arrêté dans
une boulangerie du val de mougins
seulement personne ici ne s'en souvient
à 12h15 omar est arrivé chez lui au
cannet dans le hall de l'immeuble au
mardi avoir vu le gérant d'un
supermarché voisin
une présence que confirme ce dernier à
12h45 aux mains repart vers mougins et
s'arrête à 12h51 pour appeler ses
beaux-parents conversation confirmée par
france télécom omar reprendra son
travail à 13h05 pour l'accusation
omar n'a pas d'alibi pour la défense ce
timing serré ne lui permettait pas de
commettre le crime
autre point de discordance le mobile
c'était un flambeur
les uns ce n'était pas son intérêt
disent les autres tu es quelqu'un qui le
faisait vivre un peu aussi puisqu'il
avait séjourné je vois pas pourquoi ils
ont supprimé ça résultat les magistrats
d'aix se retrouvent cet après midi
devant une énigme et fasse un
réquisitoire accablant la défense pointe
le doigt vers un dossier plein de
faiblesse l'homme qui se présente ce
matin devant ses juges offre deux images
d'abord celle d'un accusé souriant
détendu confiant
celle enfin d'un homme impatient lorsqu
il attend quelques minutes dans un
couloir que le président armand jay en
donne l'ordre de le faire comparaître
dans le box un patient de clamer son
innocence publiquement car depuis les
faits en juin 91
omar raddad ni mais depuis deux ans et
demi la justice ne veut pas l'entendre
pour elle le crime est signé de la main
même de la victime omar m'a tuer
face à lui la soeur de ghislaine marchal
est le fils de la victime tous deux
assisté de m henri leclerc attendent de
ce procès
confirmation de leurs soupçons omar
toujours souriant quand il aperçoit au
fond de la salle
son père quant à la défense elle a subi
une rupture il ya trois jours les
divergences dans l'attitude à adopter
on poussait les deux avocats présents
depuis le début a quitté le dossier
seuls restent donc maître vergès maîtres
pétillot ce matin assistant l'accusé un
interprète un interprète dont la défense
dénonce amèrement l'absence aux côtés de
leurs clients lors des premiers
interrogatoires
chose rare lors de l'ouverture d'un
procès devant une cour d'assises
l'absence ce matin des pièces à
conviction
cela souligne bien la difficulté de
cette affaire car l'arme du crime par
exemple n'a pas été retrouvé les
éléments matériels sont minces si ce
n'est inexistant aux douze jurés donc de
la cour d'assises des alpes maritimes de
dire dans une dizaine de jours
quelle lecture ils font de cette
inscription en lettres de sang omar
raddad est il la sacem de ghislaine
marchal toujours pas de réponse à la
cour d'assises des alpes maritimes pour
tenter de l'obtenir magistrats et jurés
veulent déceler le mobile et mieux
connaître la victime dominique
verdeilhan et gilles dobler sont à nice
de la sphère de l'accusé christian
veilleux ne veux pas parler une
se limitera donc à évoquer par quelques
mots la victime
nous avions 19 ans d'écart plus qu'une
mère ce fut une amie une confidente
ma mère dit il avait un profond respect
pour les autres sa mort fut un drame
épouvantable et cela continuera sans
doute mais je pense que n'importe qui
perd dans une mer c'est déjà affreux
mais dans ces conditions là je crois que
effroyable pour ses amis la riche
héritière des landes marshall n'était
pas la mondaine évaporé qu'on a voulu
dépeindre ghislaine marchal était une
femme de caractère juste mais exigeante
avec ses employés solitaire discrète
secrète à la chamade sa villa sa vie
était calme et ranger il aurait fallu
des sévices très grave pour la faire
écrire ce qu'elle ne voulait pas avance
un de ses amis madame marchal cinglante
et agacé selon sa femme de ménage
lorsque omar venaient lui demander une
nouvelle fois une avance des familiers
de madame marchal qui évoque aussi sa
passion des mots croisés ou il reconnaît
un témoin allaient chercher leurs taux
graff exact dans les dictionnaires
oui écrire tu es er elle en était
capable
je vous le promets non quand on a god is
on ne fait pas la dictée de bernard
pivot
rien de déterminant donc mais c'est là
au moins le mérite de faire rentrer le
procès dans une enquête qui elle non
plus ne manque pas de faute
au chapitre de la justice la suite du
procès d'omar raddad à nice à la journée
était consacrée aux circonstances de la
mort de ghislaine marchal
dominique verdeilhan a suivi cette
audience ce matin et en début d'après
midi
compte rendu trois pièces à conviction
pour tenter de résoudre une énigme un
lit pliant un chevron de voix une barre
métallique point commun les trois objets
sont maculés de sang celui de la victime
ce sont là pour les jurés les seuls
éléments matériels et visible de ce
dossier à eux de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé le 23 juin 91 dans la cave
le lendemain lorsque les gendarmes
tentent de pénétrer dans le sous sol de
la ville là il constate deux choses
primo la porte est fermée à clé à double
tour secundo l'ouverture se fait
difficilement à l'audience face aux
jurés
un des gendarmes reconstitue le
mécanisme qui bloquaient la porte
le lit et la barre métallique en
position de le
et pour empêcher l'ouverture pour la
défense d'omar ce dispositif accrédite
la thèse de la machination
mais le gendarme est catégorique pour
lui il est impossible de monter un tel
mécanisme
en sortant de la cave autrement dit la
personne qui a écrit omar m'a tuer et
qui s'est barricadé et la mène les 12
jurés comprennent donc aujourd'hui la
difficulté de leur tâche avant d'être
d'eau juge
on leur demande de se transformer en
sherlock holmes
c'est demain que mara date sera fixée
sur son sort aujourd'hui devant la cour
d'assises des alpes-maritimes
l'avocat général a requis une peine de
17 à 20 ans de réclusion criminelle pour
je cite un crime par excellence crime de
lâcheté d'indifférence et d'horreur
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan hervé pozzo l'argent
donc pas de trace de larmes pas de trace
de l'argent deux constats que l'on
retrouvera sûrement demain dans la
plaidoirie de maître vergès
car avant de convaincre les jurés
l'avocat plaide l'innocence de son
client dans la salle des pas perdus
quelques instants auparavant l'avocat
général avait requis entre 17 et 20 ans
de réclusion criminelle
pour bernard farret dix éléments
convergents font une preuve
ghislaine marchal dit il n'a pas pu se
tromper de bonne foi le meurtrier a agi
de face elle l'a donc parfaitement
identifiés tout nous ramène à omar
constate le magistrat
ce n'est pas un crime de rôdeur car il y
a eu ni vol ni fouille ni effraction
pour maître leclerc nous ne sommes plus
dans le mystère le roman et la fiction
nous sommes dans la douleur et l'infini
souffrance
omar m'a tuer c'est un ultime message à
la famille et à vous les juges il ne
faut pas nier ce message demande
l'avocat maître leclerc qui souligne
qu'il n'a pas besoin des experts pour se
forger une conviction absolue il y a
aucune contestation possible toute autre
hypothèse est absurde mais plus fort
encore que les mots des plaidoiries et
du réquisitoire il y a ceux de la
victime le président armand djian avait
pris soin de laisser devant les 12 jurés
les deux portes et leur inscription
comme si au delà de cette ultime message
courageux de madame marchal
on voulait y voir aussi ses dernières
volontés
bonsoir omar raddad condamné à 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle les jurés de la
cour d'assises des alpes maritimes l'ont
donc reconnu coupable du meurtre de
ghislaine marchal décision au terme d'un
long délibéré de 7h ce matin maître
vergès son avocat avait demandé son
acquittement à nice
clément weill raynal et christos
camillieri ce après six heures et demie
de délibérations le verdict tombe
omar raddad est déclaré coupable du
meurtre de ghislaine marchal la cour
d'assises lui accorde des circonstances
atténuantes et le condamne à 18 ans de
prison
la soeur d'omar raddad fond en larmes et
quitte immédiatement le prétoire
latifa sa femme s'est évanouie victime
d'une crise de nerfs
dans le public la sentence est
accueillie avec silence c'est maître
vergès qui réagit le plus violemment en
s'adressant directement à la foule où
quelqu'un dont j'ai prouvé l'innocence a
été condamné à une peine à une peine
qu'il ne mérite pas
c'est la célébration du centenaire de
l'affairé dreyfus il ya cent ans
condamné un jeune officier qui avait le
tort d'être juifs
aujourd'hui on condamne au jardinier
parce qu'il a le tort maghrébins
visiblement choqués le père d'omar
raddad se refuse à toute déclaration et
s'en va en silence la femme de marc
haddad est évacué en ambulance après une
brève bousculade
le calme semblait revenir autour du
palais de justice il ya moins d'une demi
heure
omar raddad reste donc en prison je vous
le disais la cour de cassation vient à
l'instant de rejeter le pourvoi formé
par ce jardinier marocain condamné à 18
ans de prison pour le meurtre de sa
patronne la décision vient donc d'être
rendus sur place dominique verdeilhan au
fil de la lecture de l'arrêt maître
jacques vergès comprend omar raddad
vient de perdre un nouveau combat avec
la justice il ne sera pas rejugé après
trois heures de débat près de trois
heures de délibéré les magistrats de la
cour de cassation vienne purement et
simplement de confirmer le verdict de
nice omar raddad est donc définitivement
condamné
les magistrats n'ont pas suivi les
avocats d'omar raddad pour ces derniers
leurs clients n'avaient pas été jugés
dans les règles de l'art
l'arrêt de la cour d'assises était
entachée suspecte parce que
dactylographié pré-rédigés et faisant de
omar raddad un condamné d'avancé tu es
là pour la défense la manifestation
prohibé de l'opinion du président de la
cour d'assises des alpes-maritimes ma
réaction est d'une très grande déception
déception non seulement pour omar raddad
qui est innocent des crimes pour
lesquels il a été condamné
mais déception pour la justice aussi
parce que dans les attendus que j'ai
entendu je pense qu'il y à un recul des
droits de la der du respect des droits
de la défense
la cassation tant attendu par omar
raddad mais aussi par une partie de
l'opinion
au public n'a donc pas lieu et c'est la
deuxième fois qu omar haddad ne
bénéficie pas du tout
à nice il s'agissait d'un doute quant à
sa culpabilité
a paris il s'agissait d'un doute quant à
l'équité de son procès les avocats
maintenant d'omar raddad savent qu'ils
n'ont plus qu'un seul recours une
révision de son procès mais les avocats
le savent la justice n'aime pas dire
qu'elle s'est trompée
madame monsieur bonsoir le président
public a décidé aujourd'hui de faire
usage de son droit de grâce en faveur
d'omar raddad son jardinier condamné en
1994 à 18 ans de prison pour le meurtre
de sa patronne ghislaine marchal d'agra
ce n'est que partiel mais elle devrait
permettre aux détenus d'être libérés
dans deux ans tout le monde se souvient
de la fameuse phrase écrite en lettres
de sang omar m'a tuer qui avait accusé
le jardinier qui par la suite a toujours
nié ce crime dominique verdeilhan
yasmina farmer
rada il n'est par hasard dans une prison
du sud de la france c'était avant son
procès il souriait il clamé son
innocence
il attendait confiant qu'un jury
populaire la kiffe mais en janvier 94 à
nice la cour d'assises me condamne à 18
ans de réclusion criminelle
deux ans et demi plus tard omar raddad
bénéficié d'une grâce partielle
il est dispensé de quatre ans et huit
mois de peine conséquences pour le
jardinier marocain
il pourrait bénéficier d'une libération
conditionnelle dans deux ans autrement
dit après sept ans de prison
satisfaction ce soir du père de marc
haddad connaît depuis le rejet du
pourvoi en cassation d'omar raddad sa
condamnation était devenue définitive et
rien ne semblait pouvoir remettre en
question ce verdict de mal compris par
l'opinion publique aussi bien française
que marocaine le roi hassan ii s'est ému
plusieurs fois du sort du jardinier
marocain et avait demandé à avocats et
détectives de mener une contre-enquête
en vain la grâce partielle intervient
donc à l'issue du voyage officiel en
france du roi du maroc
mais pour les avocats d'omar le mystère
de la chamade la villa où a été
assassiné ghislaine marchal n'est pas
élucidé alors il continue de réunir les
éléments qui permettraient une révision
du procès de marc adha nous avons réuni
un certain nombre d'éléments
ces éléments seront exposées dans le
cadre d'un recours en révision pour nous
la faire ne sera définitive ne classe et
que lorsque l'innocence d'omar raddad
n'aura été reconnue cette grâce
présidentielle ni ne sentent pas pour
autant omar haddad mais elle condamne en
filigramme notre procédure criminelle et
plaide pour un des projets de jacques
toubon le garde des sceaux la
possibilité de faire appel devant une
cour d'assises première art de liberté
donc pour omar haddad qui a quitté à la
levée d'écrou la centrale de muret après
plus de sept années de réclusion
l'ancien jardinier marocain bénéficier
on s'en souvient d'une grâce partielle
de jacques chirac en 96
aujourd'hui omar haddad qui a toujours
clamé son innocence veut continuer à se
battre pour obtenir sa réhabilitation
valérie ermite christophe la rocca
plus de sept ans comme un rat date en ce
moment ils tombent dans les bras de son
avocat 8h05 ce matin à la sortie de la
prison de muret omar raddad est un homme
heureux mais il est aussi un homme
stressé à l'extérieur des dizaines de
journalistes l'attendent pour recueillir
ses premiers mots très content
aujourd'hui je suis pas très content
avec ça pour rien et qui me l'a déjà kg
soulèverait le combat jusqu'au bout
ça veut dire je serai l'apéritif omar
raddad est libre mais pour la justice il
n'est qu'un coupable en liberté son
innocence celle qui proclame depuis
toujours il l'a voudrait officielle et
reconnue
il a sa liberté aujourd'hui
maintenant il s'agit de lui restituer
son nom
et quand je pense plus quand je dis
restitue son honneur embarrasse les
restitue son honneur la justice
française c'est à aix en provence commun
raddad a goûté sa première journée de
liberté
c'est la première fois qu'il revient sur
le meurtre de ghislaine marchal est sûre
son arrestation le tamouré m'a monté le
photo à hambach me tue je le promets
questionner m'a dit pourquoi tu as fait
ça qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai rien
fait il m'a décidé à marmoutier c'est
toi le modèle marche
mouassa démarré comme ça le jury m'a
donné la date du jour je vois passer à
la cour d'assises et détaillé les s'est
dissout les brassées a quitté sa famille
pour ça mais malheureusement pour à la
justice cet oubli
aujourd'hui ablation totale de la vérité
parce que je devais me saouler vrai mais
en même temps il soit pas libre à 100%
parce que c'est c'est quelque chose et
la déchirer ma vie redémarrer mais en
forme toute ma famille c'est quelque
chose qui peut pas vivre avec ça bon
assez et il faut la justice et que nous
y voilà
omar raddad dit n'attendre plus que cela
n'hypothèque révision de son procès que
maître vergès continent et bien omar
raddad condamné pour le meurtre de
ghislaine marchal commis en juin 91 à
mougins dans les alpes maritimes
pourraient peut-être bénéficier des
éléments d'une nouvelle expertise
scientifique confirmant que l'adn
masculin mêlée au sein de la victime
pour écrire omar m'a tuer n'est pas
celui de marde commentaire parce qu'elle
dit c'est bon omar m'a tuer ces quelques
mots écrit avec le sang de ghislaine
marchal viennent de livrer un de leurs
derniers secret les scientifiques de la
police avait détecté un adn masculin
mélangées au sang de la victime
trois tests ont été effectués deux
d'entre eux indiquent que les traces d
adn n'appartiennent pas à omar raddad
les résultats du troisième test ne sont
pas encore connus la police scientifique
parisienne remettra ses conclusions à la
justice en début de semaine prochaine
alors de qui proviennent ces fameuses
traces de salive ou de sueur mélangées
au sang de la victime
les experts n'ont pas la réponse pas
plus qu'ils ne savent à quel moment
elles ont été déposées sur la porte
avant ou pendant le meurtre après lors
des multiples manipulations personne ne
le sait pour l'instant
alors ce soir une seule chose est sûre
l'analyse n'accuse pas omar raddad
elle ne le disculpe pas pour autant
l'homme a été condamné à 18 ans de
prison par la cour d'assises de nice en
94 avant d'être partiellement gracié par
le président de la république
il a toujours clamé son innocence depuis
ses avocats se battent pour l'ouverture
d'un procès en révision
les résultats des analyses
constitue-t-il un élément nouveau pour
la cour de cassation
rien n'est moins sûr les magistrats
devraient prendre leur décision au
printemps
omar haddad sera-t-il rejugé la cour de
cassation examine demain son dossier
il avait été condamné en 94 pour le
meurtre de sa patronne ghislaine marchal
avant d'être partiellement gracié cette
affaire criminelle très médiatisé avait
déchaîné les passions à la veille de ce
nouveau rendez vous judiciaire clément
weill raynal et christian walter ont
rencontré celui qui avait mené l'enquêté
il ne doute pas de la culpabilité d'omar
raddad
le capitaine georges cenci fut l'un des
tout premiers à se rendre à la chamade
le 23 juin 81
alors que les gendarmes venaient de
découvrir dans la cave le corps de
ghislaine marchal et les fameuses
inscription en lettres de sang omar m'a
tuer c'est lui qui décide à dix jours
plus tard d'interpeller le jardinier
omar raddad et qui conduisent ils
enquêtent pendant dix mois
aujourd'hui sa conviction n'a pas changé
les inscriptions dit il sont bien de la
main de madame marchal
elle avait identifié son agresseur elle
était restée lucide tout au long de son
agonie
si vous regardez les deux messages
pendant cette agonie on voit la fée
l'affaiblissement physiologiques de
cette dame ou le premier message est
écrit en lettres que l'on reconnaît très
très facilement qu'ils sont nés les
lettres ferme décidé très très très bien
écrite et ensuite le deuxième message
qui est très très flou il faut vraiment
avoir lu le premier que pour lire le
second pc l'a ensuite aux ailes des
scènes contre l'opinion publique qui
voit en omar raddad la parfaite
incarnation de l'erreur judiciaire
georges cenci plaide la solidité du
dossier de l'accusation qui avait
entraîné la condamnation d'omar raddad à
18 ans de prison pour le capitaine de
gendarmerie
les nouvelles pistes évoquées par la
défense n'ont débouché sur rien de
sérieux
oui il ya eu le deuxième omar il y avait
eu madame clar il ya eu il ya eu les
couteaux chaque détective privé a trouvé
son couteau d épluche légumes de couteau
découverts dans le port de cannes
qu'est-ce qui a eu il faut bien tenir
l'opinion publique canal vous savez tout
ça a été fait pour préparer une demande
la révision pour l'instant ça a l'air de
marcher il pas sûr que ça marche
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je
préférerais me penser vérité judiciaire
contre vérité médiatique
demain la cour de révision se réunira
pour décider si les nouveaux éléments
présentés par la défense expertises en
écriture traces d'adn n justifie un
nouveau procès d'omar raddad pour
l'ancien jardinier
il s'agit en tout cas de la dernière
chance d'être peut-être un jour
réhabilité je suis prêt à mourir pour la
vérité omar raddad réclame donc la
révision de son procès je vous rappelle
qu'il avait été condamné à 18 ans de
prison pour le meurtre de ghislaine
marchal c'était en 91 puis gracié par le
président de la république il ya quatre
ans la cour de cassation examiné sa
requête aujourd'hui c'est plutôt mal
parti puisque le parquet s'y oppose
dominique verdeilhan eric mézil
je suis prêt à mourir pour la vérité
durant 15 minutes omar haddad s'adresse
aux juges de la cour de révision le
condamner plaide lui même sa cause
je demande mille fois un second procès
c'est moi poursuit-il qui prend le
risque d'être rejugé ça fait 12 ans
réclamés deuxième procès et pour moi et
pour toute la france parce que j'ai
parce qu'elle a beaucoup des français
réclamant deuxième procès et je pense
tous les français et son droit de se
voir la vérité site où vous avez juré
plusieurs fois j'ai joué parce que
jamais personnellement demandé
et c'est pour ça j'ai joué parce que
l'expulsion certaines de moi c'est pas
moi dans ma chair
[Musique]
et vous dites qu'il vous a tué aussi la
salsa oui parce que partie civile ait
dit et c'est qu'elle a fait ça frais
mais des fois oui il est fort le
résultat est là les tuyaux madame
marchand et me ramenait rattraperait
encore 18 ans
raddad innocent ce n'est pas un intime
conviction de laurent davenas
pour l'avocat général il n'y a pas
d'élément nouveau il n'y a pas de doute
il n'ya que des charges
il s'oppose à la révision au grand dam
de maître vergès je pense que les
déclarations de son avocat gerra sont
insignifiantes
il ya cette erreur fondamentale comment
peut-il dire que des traces adn dans le
sens d'un marshall ne signifie rien
comment peut-il le soutenir qui a écrit
omar m'a tuer à qui appartient l'adn
masculin prélevés sur les portes puisque
ce n'est pas celui d'omar raddad
douze ans après les faits ce sont les
interrogations de la défense expertise à
l'appui des expertises qui pour
l'accusation et la partie civile ne
remettent pas en cause la culpabilité de
radanne je suis réconforté par le fait
que le ministère public partage mon
analyse du dossier
c'est à dire encore une fois celle des
faits et pas celle des déclarations
tapageuses ces dernières expertises sont
elles de la propagande mensongère comme
le pense laurent davenas cela
condamnation d'omar raddad et l
abracadabrante comme le soutient jacques
vergès la cour de révision donnera sa
réponse le 20 devant le combat de ma
raddad qui veut que son innocence soit
reconnue
il a demandé aujourd'hui la révision de
sa condamnation dans un mois les juges
diront s'il peut bénéficier d'un nouveau
procès l'avocat général s'est prononcé
contre estimant qu'il est coupable du
meurtre de son ancienne patronne clément
weill-raynal nathalie berthier dernière
étape devant la cour de révision douze
ans après le meurtre de ghislaine
marchal
omar raddad désigné par les mystérieux
inscriptions en lettres de sang omar
raddad condamné à 18 ans de prison
espère toujours obtenir la révision de
son procès
essentiel à propos des français
et clément deuxième procès et je pense
c'est en vérité judiciaire contre vérité
médiatique deux thèses se sont affrontés
ce matin devant la cour de révision
que valent les traces d adn retrouvées
sur les portes taché de sang que vaut la
remise en cause des expertises en
écriture attribuant les inscriptions
accusatrice à ghislaine marchal rien
estime maître kiejman l'avocat de la
famille marchal rejoint par l'avocat
général laurent davenas assez
d'approximations tempête le représentant
du ministère public assez de poudre aux
yeux
dans ce dossier il y à des faits qui ont
entraîné la condamnation d'omar raddad
et qui pèse plus lourd que de prétendues
révélations
il y à un débat contradictoire devant
des juges
c'est à dire un débat au cours duquel on
ne peut pas affirmer n'importe quoi sans
prendre le risque de contredire
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on s'est
rapproché de la vérité du dossier
ça plus possible de dire que l'enquêté
avait été bâclée qu'il sera plus
possible de dire qu'il n'existait pas de
charges
c'est dans un peu plus d'un mois le 20
novembre prochain que la cour de
révision se fera connaître sa décision
si la cour suit l'avocat général dans
ses réquisitions et rejette la demande
de révision
ce sera cette fois un point final à la
faire omar raddad
[Musique]